New York Post has this has this article
the mother of the hulking Florida teen
who beat his female teacher unconscious
over a Nintendo switch video game
claimed that prison time would be a
death sentence for her convicted son
lyanna DEA who uh pleaded for leniency
for the now 18-year-old Brendan DEA who
faces up to 30 years behind bars for
slamming paraprofessional Joanne Nack to
the floor before kicking and punching
her in the back and head more than a
dozen times please consider that my son
has had a hard life
and he's gone through so much trauma in
his life he has
autism please show Mercy to him whether
we understand the mother's feeling here
or not doesn't matter because I think
the answer from the court system should
be no please have mercy on my son no